coming up on Star Talk Cosmic queries
galaxies Galore you're going to learn
about how we get the distances to things
in the universe and what else is going
on with the James web Space Telescope
messing with our tidy theories of the
early Universe all that and more coming
up on Star
[Music]
Talk this is Star Talk Neil degrass
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
co-host Chuck Nice chuck all right man
how you doing I'm doing great how's it
going Neil yeah we a little overdue for
another Cosmic queries yes which is
always a fan favorite and the top
apparently today has a topic oh we've
been doing a lot of Galactic gumbo
lately but this one
is just grab bag of of of but this one
is Galaxy's Galore so maybe are they all
about G galaxies is that what must be
galaxies are my thing you know me and
galaxies go way back let's hope
so well I'm on the wrong show all right
so bring it on okay let's get to it
let's get right to it uh we got Bruce
Ryan who says greetings jents who
changed his name so that you could
pronounce it just thought I would tell
you yes I'm sure you know and by the way
thank you Bruce yes I actually I should
thank your parents you know
uh he says greetings jents I'd love to
know how you determine how far away
stars or even galaxies are from Earth
and isn't that distance based on the
light we're seeing now as opposed to the
actual distance given the expansion of
the universe thanks in advance Bruce
Ryan all right well look at that so so I
there two ways I can answer that one is
completely lazy all right all right all
right so I'll give that answer answer
second no give the lazy answer first
really okay I mean unless it's just
unless it's like
yes if it's that lazy no no no the lazy
answer is our second star talk book
published with National Geographic
called Cosmic queries has an entire
section on how astronomers find
distances to things in the
universe and it was called the distance
ladder it's called the distance ladder
because you figure out the distance to
nearby things and then you step on that
rung and that enables you to then think
about distances to the next categories
of objects because the same methods
don't apply at all distances right so
the the objects that are farther away
depend on the accuracy of methods and
tools you used for for closer objects
right on down to the distances to nearby
stars and even the planets themselves
right I was going to say does that apply
to the planets right right so so my
answer to you is read the damn book the
dam that's the lazy answer read the book
yeah that if you get cos nice big fat
book makes a good gift but there's an
entire a lot of energy was put many many
pages on this so just so you know and
yes by the time we get to galaxies their
light has been traveling for great uh
time to before it reaches us but we have
other evidence to show that the speed of
light has been constant not only across
space but also through the depths of
time otherwise we would be we would not
be getting the right answers to things
that are far away which depend on the
light travel time and things like this
and how fast they're moving in the
expanding Universe there's a lot of
interdependent factors there but so
that's the that's the that's the easy
answer answer but I'll give you just a I
I'll I'll give you a starter answer to
get you ready for when you get the book
when you get the okay okay so here it is
so we have two eyes and if you put your
two fingers out in front of you you can
have them hit each other every time okay
you're using a stereoscopic vision to
make that happen if you try that with
one eye okay try try put your arm your
fingers at Arms distance and use two
eyes and have them connect to each other
okay just do that can you do that okay
easy so now now bring your hands back in
okay close one eye okay put your arms
out now try it again okay oh my
gosh
whoa all right first of all uh officer I
do not think that this is a fair test
I'm just saying uh you know I have one
beer at work and quite frankly I wow
that is that's a amazing so let the
record show that chuck could not have
his fingers neither could I I'm I close
one eye put my hands back and I miss it
by an inch so or centimeter yeah so but
you have to like you know refresh the
right right you can't because if you
just leave it there your brain actually
makes up the difference and does it for
you you because because you know what
you're trying to do right so with two
eyes you do it right okay you do it
every time boom boom bring your hands
back one eye do it and you miss look at
that so what we did was it's a it's a
method of triangulation you have two
angles of view so in other words if you
have one sight line that intersects it
could be anywhere along the sight line
right if you have two sight lines those
two sight lines intersect at a single
point right and geometrically you can
know exactly the distance to that object
using this method so we my people are
very clever
very clever we said let's do that with
the Earth's orbit right right the
Earth's orbit okay because consider the
farther away something is the less
useful this separation of your eyes will
be right okay think about it right if
something is a mile away you can't use
stere Vision to get a distance to it
exactly it's just far all right stars
are far so how do you help out the the
Baseline of what would be your eye your
eye sockets for something that's that
far away you use the entire orbit of
orbit of the of the Earth around oh wow
a that something so like one eye it is
one eye is Earth in June and the other
eye is Earth in December right so
because they're in two different spots
it's your left eye and your right eye
and then you have a sight line and then
you look for the points where they come
together different sight lines of okay
and so so here the way this works is my
God that is so simple and so smart my
people these are my people these are my
people okay proud of my people okay yeah
so you get the nearby stars and it turns
out they they're far but they're close
enough for this method to work and
here's what you do you take a picture of
that star against the background Stars
okay okay and it's gonna be sitting in
front of some pattern then you wait 6
months you take that same picture again
and your sight line on that star has
changed and now it's sitting slightly in
front of a different pattern of stars
very
slightly that corresponds to an angle
and that angle okay is is one part of
that
triangle and we have the base of that
triangle which is the diameter of
Earth's
orbit right because it's not the radius
it's the full diameter that's the like
the diameter between your two eyes you
do the geometry of this bottom we know
the distance from from Earth to the sun
right you need that because that's one
of the legs of this
triangle before we knew the distance
from Earth to the sun you could not
successfully apply this method because
you'd be missing one of the dimension
you let's say you had the wrong
measurement here that wrong measurement
would eek its way into these other
measurements
and propagate through all of your
estimates for the distances to stars in
your neighborhood so the an before
before we knew the sun was 93 million
miles away the answer to this question
was woo you don't even want to
know I never thought of giving that
answer to
questions how how far is the next star
after the sun oh you don't even want to
know you don't even want to know that's
far so so that's why it's a ladder
because any error at the base level of
this would propagate to all other levels
okay so now we get the distance to the
nearby Stars okay now we hope what well
we made sure one of those stars is like
the sun okay now we know the Luminosity
of the sun we're orbiting the damn thing
and Luminosity is how much energy it's
giving off M
so if I know how much energy it's giving
off then I start putting it farther and
farther away from
me it gets dimmer doesn't it of course
yeah if I know what its intrinsic
Luminosity
is then I can calculate the rate at
which it gets dimmer as it moves away
from me it's called the one the the
inverse Square law of light okay so if I
find another star like the sun I get
spectroscopically I get to say that star
is just like the sun just like our sun
right and therefore I believe I know
it's Luminosity CU I know the sun's
Luminosity right and look how dim it is
based on that I can now give you the
distance to that star with a simple
formula so then you I guess you change
it because there are a lot of different
stars with different luminosities and
some things that aren't even Stars well
well right right so so so that gets me
the distance of stars that look like the
sun right right okay but if I get a a
triangulated distance to a star that's
not like the sun like a brown dwarf or
something like brown dwarf or any red
giant or whatever and I get the
triangulated distance now I find another
star like that and then I can apply the
same method damn I know I know that is
unbeliev I'm telling you right now my
mind okay now now you want to know you
know you know to know when we dunked on
this you ready go ahead okay recently
there's a satellite called Gia Okay
Google it it is a specially tuned
satellite designed to get this
triangulated distance method to a
billion
stars rather than just the few yeah
that's because it's above Earth's
atmosphere it can measure the tiniest
angles with very high Precision oh my
gosh so now we got that we we're good we
good we can find these stars in other
galaxies and get the distance there by
the way that's what Hubble did Hubble
said okay here's a star that pulsates
okay and and it was discovered by
henrieta levit all right in in the women
of Harvard College Observatory who were
given the quote menial work of of the
laborers of calculating things with
stars they were called human computers
turns out that's what the action was and
modern Stellar astrophysics was birthed
in the room where it happened
okay to quote Hamilton in the room where
it happened all the women there's a
bunch of women who all did this work
while the men stood up in their in their
smoking lounges believing they were
contemplating the universe but the real
action with their pipes academics smoked
the pipes that's right right the
gangsters or no the the the Fat Cat smok
the cigars they fat cat smok is cigars
and academics smoked pipes I actually
when I had there was a guy I went to
school with he was a philosophy major
and he smoked a pipe and I said yes I
swear to God I swear to
God yeah and he and everybody kind of
the people were like what a what a
pompous pretentious ass right but then
one day I just asked him I was like dude
seriously why why do you smoke a pipe
and he had the pipe when I asked him and
he went because it makes me look like
I'm thinking about something when
actually there's nothing on my mind
okay this you got a h that's you got to
give it to him I was like I was like
100% you win you got no there's no
there's no comeback on that one right
right so Henry L figured
out that the rate at which the star
pulsates directly correlates with the
Luminosity of the star and again all you
need is the if all you have to do is
know the L what is the Luminosity it's
the wattage stamped on the light bulb
okay and so if you know that there's
another light bulb with the same water
but it looks much dimmer it's because
it's farther away because you otherwise
can't see distance in the universe
there's no the fact that you can't see
distance LED Legions and generations of
people to think that the stars were just
points of light on the inside of a dome
on the surface of a dome leaving them to
think that constellations were real
things okay but now these are they're
scattered in space and since you and
they just they any angle of view on them
they look completely different they're
not real things they're completely in
your head okay so so stars are scattered
in space so if so once you knew this
Hubble found one of these variable stars
in The Andromeda
nebula and he measured its pulsation
rate deduced the Luminosity then
calculated its distance and it was a
holy moment this nebula is not in
the Milky Way It Is Way Beyond the
limits of the Milky Way in fact it's an
entire other
Galaxy the Andromeda nebula overnight
became the Andromeda galaxy oh snap yes
all of these guy we didn't know what
they these were just nebuli we just
called them nebula fuzzy spiral fade
they were just nebuli why would why
would we think there's anything other
than our own system that's got a little
bit of our ego playing out there okay
there's another Island Universe out
there an island Galaxy there it was and
then that opened up the entire universe
and that happened between 1926 and
1929 we're we are in the Centennial
decade of discovering how big the
universe really is because of a distance
method to determine a method to
determine the distance to this kind of
variable star discovered by Henryetta
levit in the Harvard College Observatory
unbelievable wait then once he got the
distance to Andromeda he could get
distances to other galaxies with methods
similar and then he found out that the
galaxies are receding from us and the
farther away the galaxy is the faster
it's moving away well if that's an
actual relationship then you don't need
to separately know the distance you just
have to measure how fast it's moving
away which you could do using the
Doppler shift just measure the speed
moving away from us and and you put it
in the Hubble equation and out pops the
distance so that is the ultimate that's
the highest rung of the distance ladder
What's called the red shift of the
object which was based ultimately on
variable Stars traceable to nearby
galaxies traceable in our galaxy
traceable to the triangulation method
traceable all the way back to to to um
just looking at stereoscopically with
your eyes look at that that's amazing
well
well I got one more wait wait wait wait
wait wait wa gotta be kidding me there
can't be more if there's an
object where the angle
changes by one arcc okay an arcc is
160th of an arc minute this is angles
now even though it sounds like time
160th of an arc minute and an arc minute
is 160th of a degree okay okay that's
how small these angles are right all
right well that makes sense okay okay so
we have up degrees minutes
seconds
so if there were an object at a distance
such that the this angle was one Arc
second by the way this you know what we
call this angle changing up we call it a
parallax okay have heard that word
before yeah The Parallax is the angle
change in a oh by the way have you ever
been on big deal on 3D 3D film making EX
okay exactly they care about that all
the time the bigger the parallx the
closer your brain puts the object to you
you use your brain uses Parallax to
judge what's close and what's far okay
right right so and the farther away it
is the lower The Parallax that's why the
moon follows you when you walk oh look
at
[Music]
that and here I thought it was just
me the Moon is so far away from you and
your eyes that you don't see a change in
the angle on it against the background
so it looks like it f whereas the trees
have very high Parallax right as you
walk by them so they have the highest
Parallax the the the trees across the
street have a lower Parallax buildings
near the Horizon okay uh the moon would
eventually pass you by if you kept
walking for another 300,000 miles but
that that's that's what you would need
to get a big enough angle for that to
happen all right let me get back to this
so an object whose
Parallax is 1 AR
second is at a distance of one
parseek
what that's amazing that's where we get
the distance Parc from look at that now
now I lied a little that it's a little
more complicated it's half angle is one
Arc second just because that's how we
Define it the angle that connects to the
sun rather than to the full Baseline but
that's just a geometric Factor there so
you've heard parek used in Star
Trek sing movie ever yeah and our boy in
in Star Wars did the kessle run in 12
parex right which is profoundly ignorant
of what a parek is because a parek is a
unit of distance it's not a unit of time
time and then the apologist got online
said here Dr Tyson here's why he says
parex and it made up some total BS
about it was a dist he found a loop that
was shorter and that's why he did it in
12 par sex instead of 15 part so they
and I said all right I I'm staying away
from this community of fans because Star
Wars is
Magic let's okay let's be honest so
that's the whole so I'm sorry I I blew
half the time of this episode talking
but it was very important and it took us
I would say 60 years to fully develop
that distance ladder and we're still
improving it oh by the way we later
would find out that Hubble was using a
different kind of variable star than the
one Henry Eda levit had used okay um but
it still correlated in that way but it
had a different correction factor and
once they corrected the factor the size
of the universe was it doubled or Haled
I again because it was it was the
foundation for the later measurements
and so that so that's how that that that
uncertainty can creep in to the other
measurements but there it is amazing
that's really cool and all of that is in
Cosmic queries all of it all of it all
of it and a whole section called The
Cosmic distance ladder look at that I
guess now you don't have to buy the book
but you kind of do because you you do
because you need to you need to go ahead
and get that information so that you can
have it as a reference yeah as a
reference and it's fully is it's more
organizationally laid out than I could
possibly deliver in this uh thing yeah
cool introducing the all electric Ford
Mustang Mach E SUV Ford is electrifying
its icons to keep the sole of driving
alive while shifting towards an electric
vehicle future the Mustang Mach e is an
SUV with the Bold style of a Mustang
which means you can make a bold
statement and still be practical the
2023 Mustang Mach e GT performance
Edition SUV achieves 0 to 60 mph in 3.5
seconds it's an EV with exhilarating
torque and available features like
electric all-wheel drive and a drive
mode called unbridle it has room for you
your people and your things with five
seats and a frunk otherwise known as a
front trunk experience the freedom and
Thrill of the drive while knowing your
needs can still be met learn more about
the all electric Ford Mustang Mach E SUV
at 4 4.com
slsv
slachy e due to high demand and Global
Supply Chain constraints some models
Trims and features may not be available
or may be subject to change check with
your local dealer for current
information for the 0 to 60 mph in 3.5
seconds Ford test data is based on a
typical industry methodology using one
foot rollout your results May Vary
all right what do you got all right this
is Mike Parker another another great
name another good one okay Parker he
says hello Dr Tyson and Chuck uh Mike
from Richmond Virginia here the James
web Space Telescope is seemingly
providing scientists with more questions
than it is
answers what is in your opinion how can
we be seeing massive galaxies just after
the big bang and what changes to
cosmology do you see occurring as a part
of the data so far
so I mean two questions but why is it
that James web sees things in a timeline
much closer to the origin of the
universe as opposed to other
telescopes and what do we know now that
we didn't know before
because we can see that okay so so
couple things first I I'm I'm actually
an adopted son of Richmond Virginia I
don't know if really from Richmond yeah
I have an honorary doctorate from the
University of Richmond oh very cool yes
I I do so I think about Richmond often
and so a I've actually been to Virginia
Beach oh okay music festival there
absolutely yeah as a all right it's a
great music so uh they said it seems
that telescope is ask is posing more
questions than answers that's what any
good telescope ought to do okay so in in
science we have to learn to love the
questions themselves yes lest we become
irritated by not having the answers we
seek or maybe the questions we ask are
not even what should be asked because we
don't know what question to ask because
we're not standing in the right place
yet to ask it sometimes you ask a
question and it leads you to a better
question for
example what kind of cheese is the moon
made out of right that question has no
meaning but if you set up devices you go
to the Moon you say no there it's in
fact it's not made of any kind of cheese
right maybe it's made of rocks okay so
there you go so a good experiment will
be a Launchpad for other questions so
indeed the telescope discovered five
galaxies was it six or five that where
they where the sun don't shine where it
ain't supposed to be this telescope is
exquisitely tuned to observe the birth
of galaxies so it is going right where
we wanted it to go and we don't have a
good answer to it yet okay excellent do
we maybe we don't understand the birth
of galaxies enough to put them there in
our distance calculation right it's our
distance we just spent a whole time
talking about the distance ladder maybe
there's some failure of the distance
ladder at that point or we just don't
understand how matter goes from energy
and and matter into solid objects okay
right all right so yeah yeah we so so
we're not disturbed by this we are
Overjoyed that we are stumped and we
spend we spend most of our Lives stumped
at the chalkboard or the what the
drawing board the the Whiteboard right
that's very cool you know and by the way
uh it don't have to be a white board
there's also black
board okay I'm just
saying so yeah it's it's it's not a
problem it's a it's a wonderful
challenge that we're all scratching our
heads over awesome all right let's go to
Colin Brum and Colin says greetings from
a small town in Iowa I have a question
about dark matter if it is rarely or
completely non self-interacting
shouldn't a majority of dark matter
particles fall directly to the center of
galaxies since there's effectively
nothing stopping them is this a
contributing factor to how possibly
super massive black holes got so big oh
he saying super super massive black okay
so dark matter is is is is mysterious
gravity is what it is it's literally
dark gravity it has gravity we don't
know what's causing it it's not black
hole it's not dark clouds it's not
comets asteroids it's it's no ordinary
matter is causing what we're calling
dark matter it's the longest unsolved
problem in modern astrophysics it's been
with us for 90 years since the 1930s
okay so just let's put it out there so
now um here's what's interesting about
Dark Matter a property not shared with
ordinary matter ordinary matter when it
collapses it sticks together right
because other forces other well gravity
will will take it at once it comes
together molecular forces kick in where
you get solid
objects okay what's holding a rock
together it's not gravity no it's
electromagnetic forces what's holding
you together me together it's
electromagnetic force holding our
molecules together no such corresponding
force holds Dark Matter
together so people say could we find
Dark Matter galaxies Dark Matter planets
everything we know about Dark Matter
says it cannot
coales into quote solid Dark Matter
objects it would just pass because not
only does not dark matter not interact
with us it doesn't interact with
itself okay so it'll feel its gravity
but there's no con place of
concentration for it it'll just con
it'll just continually move through
space hanging out in the hood but not
causing discret dense objects and so we
have no expectation that dark matter
played any role in the formation of
black holes even though the formation of
supermassive black holes remains a
little bit mysterious to us and guess
what if it's not if it's non interactive
it wouldn't be interactive with the with
the black hole anyway or it wouldn't be
feeding the black hole you no no but
what it would do yeah so you would where
the mass is so this this this Mass blob
called Dark Matter does attract regular
matter into the blob it will do that
okay okay so regular matter is like the
froth in the ocean of in the waves of
the ocean there are these huge waves
which we don't see and regular matter is
the froth okay but you look at the froth
the froth are these little things but
the wave is huge that's great okay
that's great that's great compared with
the froth the waves are huge so the dark
matter is spread out over the Galaxy
clusters over the Galaxy but you can't
point to one spot and say there's where
the dark matter is hanging out that spot
go that's going to pull you in no it's a
general Gathering of regular matter in
the vicinities of dark matter so wow
look at that so there are there there
are causal effects but it is not
interacting with us correct correct and
that matters if you don't interact you
can't make an object we don't think
about it that way but you know when you
make a snowball what are you doing
you're squeezing it so that it the the
the snow sort of melts under pressure
and it Sol it makes a solid object so
there's a lot we take for granted about
why things stick together in our world
uh but in the world of dark matter that
it's not the case wow okay man thank you
Colin what a great question hey let's go
to our old friend Kevin the
suoer Kevin the S Kevin Theo who says
hey we got it's a prerequisite we got to
know what wine is's recommending for
this question and you know what he
didn't give I can't believe it he didn't
give us Hey Kevin man what's the problem
you normally give us Kevin if you gon be
on a line here exactly man got hook us
up okay skipping this no
no skip his ass I
don't all right all right I know we're
uh we're recording this at a time that's
approaching the holiday season so a
glass of Port would be very look at that
are you a Tony man or I'm I can do Tony
and Ruby different moves yeah right okay
okay so uh Kevin there I am doing your
work for you there you go Kevin look at
that all right uh Kevin says I read
There were discoveries of galaxies
forming in the cosmic Dark Ages yes this
is what the other question was about
right that's what because it's before
stars formed right so we called it the
Dark Ages and we didn't expect any find
anything there and there they were and
there they were exactly okay so does
this puts back on the age of the
universe the colus must back ear than we
originally thought so but we don't know
yeah yeah so that's the same that
basically the same question we don't
know we got top people working on it and
we're still scratching our heads there
it is so this is f Hayek and F Hayek
says hello Dr Tyson Lord nice this is f
haak f Hayak from Indianapolis in
Indiana on the nature of the expansion
of the
universe is it that the Galaxy are
racing away from each other into
nothingness or that the fabric of space
time is dilating while the relatively
distance between the galaxies is really
not affected or is the expansion a mere
Deep Field Effect created by fundamental
misinterpret misinterpretation as to why
red shifting exists look at that he's so
got three things he's everywhere with
this question all over all over and in
it so no it's a simple it's a simple
answer so um other than what we call
random motions but they're not really
random we call them that random motions
of galaxies near each other so we're
we're Falling Towards
Andromeda um that's a nearby Galaxy
there's some other galaxies and clusters
if you take a step back and you look at
the large scale structure of the
universe galaxies are moving away from
one another if you just take a step back
okay when you you get up close the ones
near each other will be in orbit but
take a step back clusters of galaxies
even isolated galaxies all moving away
from us they are embedded in the fabric
of space and time and is that fabric
that is itself stretching carrying the
galaxies along with it as though you
drew on the surface of a balloon and
then you started inflating the balloon
and then the fabric of the balloon is
stretching the galaxies are not
separating from each other within the
balloon itself right they're embedded in
the surface and the surface is
stretching that is the signature of the
expanding universe and we measure that
look at that yeah fantastic it's a great
question man Jaden Peters says greetings
Dr Tyson uh Jaden Peters aspiring
astrophysicist from Ogden Utah here nice
nice I currently help to manufacture the
motors for the emis programs it's my
first time asking a question and I'm
extremely excited to do so excellent
look at that he's well listen Artemis is
the NASA's return to the Moon the Moon
and emis in Greek mythology is the twin
sister of Apollo oh look at that and by
the way uh if anything goes wrong with
the mission we know now who to blame oh
he call himself sorry sorry Jaden called
himself out all right that's right so uh
my question is as follows he says what
are the necessary Technologies for alien
life to visit us and is it likely that
Ali have any interest in Earth at all if
they are so technologically Superior to
us to allow Interstellar travel what use
could they possibly have for Earth thank
you so much so first I agree in
principle that why would we be
interesting to them at all with our
backwards ass Technologies if they have
Interstellar space travel however they
might be interested in just life
existing anywhere in the universe as are
we we're searching other planets for
life of any kind if we found microbial
life that would be amazing worms octop
octopoid whatever we would find that
amazing for our bi for our biologist so
I don't want to deny them the the power
of curiosity to see all the ways life
can matter can manifest as life in the
Galaxy or across the universe that's my
first reply
second uh maybe they live much longer
than we do and that would be the real
issue yeah if they live a billion years
then so what if it takes them you know
100,000 years or half a million years to
to travel would care yeah yeah so that's
one factor second Factor if they do have
our limited life expectancy then they
would need something like wormholes
right wormholes without wormholes uh
which are portals through the fabric of
SpaceTime where you don't have to
Traverse the entire path because you
just cut a hole through yeah you cut a
hole it's like uh oh you know I someone
made me a worm hole I have one on my
desk over there uh should should I get
it yeah well now we have to
no you can't just say you got you can't
say you got a wormhole sitting on your
desk and just leave it
there I had a 12-year-old kid who who
who 3D printed a wormhole and he gave it
to me after one of my public talks right
he didn't sign it so I you know know I
have the kids's name so I got here hold
on M all right sorry for those who are
only listening to this podcast but I
have a wormhole in my hand and it is you
see the fabric of space and time as this
ribbon and the ribbon is
curved and the two edges of the ribbon
are connected by two sort of
dimples and you can Trav you can cross
this dimple without having to go the
full length of this journey to get to
where you're going and so this curvature
of space enables this Wormhole to to
exist and so then you just Jump Through
the Wormhole and you get there instantly
yeah if we had Wormhole if Star Trek had
wormholes they wouldn't need
Transporters no exactly and you
certainly wouldn't need warp drives
would you wouldn't even need warp drives
you just you just open up a wormhole
open up a wormhole and get to where you
going Andy you know who does that every
episode is Rick Rick and Morty on Rick
and Morty you know does it on every
movie uh no dror strange oh yeah okay he
just but he does it with magic yes
whereas Rick does it with real science
just want to distinguish those two okay
exactly case you were curious yeah yeah
exactly we don't we don't want to demean
Rick's accomplishments exactly exactly
exactly yeah that's very cool man all
right time for one more question what do
you have oh that's all damn I know cuse
I blew the half the show answering the
distance L yeah well I got D didn't buy
the book apparently well
this is Christopher Pence uh who says
hey Chris Pence here from San Diego
California fairly new to patreon and not
sure if this has ever been covered but
are there any theories out there about
Dark Matter converting into Dark Energy
in any way do they relate to each other
like normal matter and normal energy
thank you for all that you do and I
absolutely love star talk excellent
excellent but we would have put his
question on even if he didn't end it
with that however uh to anybody who
writes in feel free to kiss our ass
whenever you
want I'm all about it I am all about it
love you for it love you for it
everybody needs encouragement it's so
much negativity in the world that's true
that's right anytime you want to put a
little lip print on the posterior I'm
like kudos to you thank you so much okay
now I forgot the question what was he oh
oh okay could one okay so don't overread
into the fact that we call one dark
energy and the other dark matter because
we don't know what either of them is and
I've said this before we call it Fred
and Wilma and would be just as accurate
as calling it dark energy and dark dark
matter so so Fred and Wilmer then you're
not biased in what you think it could be
right because we don't know what it is
so um could Dark Matter ever turn into
dark energy the properties of these two
entities are are so maybe but I don't
see evidence of that
because um as the universe expands
there's more Dark Energy in it but
there's not more dark matter there's not
more gravity we haven't seen this effect
right so of one converting to the other
because you'd see the effects of one
diminish and the effects of the other
increase and we don't see that happening
so I'd have to say no okay that's pretty
cool I mean that makes sense yeah Chuck
give me one more and I'm GNA sound bite
it and then we gotta call it up um this
is Charles uh
Mao and he says hey Dr Tyson and I'm
guessing Chuck um okay that's what he
said that's exactly occasionally we have
other comedians in here he's I'm
guessing it's G to be Chuck Chuck has
like other jobs you realize everybody
out there he says how has the jwst
changed our understanding of the
universe itself and will it lead to the
rewriting of
textbooks any textbook that talks about
the latest Discovery is always being
Rewritten but textbooks that talk about
discoveries that are time tested with
experiments and observations and
repeated experiments that's stays the
same so so textbooks they always want to
be Evergreen but they but no one going
buy them if it's not current so
textbooks have this issue and that's why
an online textbook is better because you
could just you can update it in real
time as you need it to so uh some things
will be Rewritten but not it's because
they weren't ever fully established in
the first place but they put something
in there here's latest thinking on
cosmology yeah so uh so we'll see it's a
new telescope in a new window on the
universe and for every new window that
has ever been opened in the history of
my field it has transformed our
understanding of the field in the in the
areas where it specialized in so I fully
expect that to happen in the in the days
weeks and years to come also
also the jamesw Space Telescope um is
just the next telescope we we're
thinking other stuff even being on this
right we're thinking of a 30 meteor
telescope oh my gosh which is would be
Far and Away the largest telescope ever
on earth or in space to see things
dimmer than ever previously imagined
because if you don't have all the
contents of the universe and you try to
develop hypotheses and theories based on
it and then someone says wait a minute
guys there's a whole other category of
object that you didn't see because your
telescopes weren't powerful enough to
see it that's embarrassing right
but that's the way of science it's you
do the best you can at any given moment
but like I said in the end we all must
learn to love the questions themselves
there you have it there it is awesome
all right Chuck we got to close out well
that was great that was a lot of fun I
gotta tell you all right all right all
right and so another episode of cosmic
queries and and that one was almost all
purely about galaxies G it was mostly
galaxies well yeah
a little dark matter you know but dark I
mean Dark Matter counts as you know
galaxies because well exctly Galaxies
have dark matter as part of them that's
right you know what I mean right very
loosely held part loosely held part of
it so you got it all right Chuck always
good to have you always a pleasure all
right Neil degrass Tyson here four star
talk as always I bid you to keep looking
up
[Music]
a